how's it going bros my name is Pam I
don't why keep dragging those huh
anyway welcome back to on e whoa ready
oh no no go hang out it's so sexy but
Jesus grad you gotta run no ah I thought
I could go right there nice to start
with game over why not I don't even know
anymore
so apparently that neutral skill Jesus
Christ what do you want from me
he wants my hair that's for sure okay
missus yeah do something yes
yes mr. Chou your life shaver howl are
you unhappy
I know okay but seriously though did I
forget to save or something what am I
going hey this is not good
I must have forgotten but I was got mr.
Sherr you're coming with me oh yeah
all right payday you're at me I'll stop
the monsters fighting you're going I'm a
Brock like I'll share more angry Oh
ah-huh now I can't look no you're not
boom chair mr. uh uh share again your
teleporting mr. share whatever
I think it's our know sign here then
it's got to be here not here
basement oh oh I know I remember I
remember I remember I remember before
you remembered like I jumped down here
how I had my penis and then I use a
basement key and this creepy I don't
need to know what it is
okay let's use the lighter oh yeah yeah
yeah
ah there's a room yeo-hwa it what
happened as a cold
the thought is locked
I found out secret door holy crap okay
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah what am I going
I'm so confused
I thought okay what's in here it's so
dark I miss chair hello penny
what are you doing here I was matched
meeting in the darkened white chairs
can't master you want to talk about all
right
she just can't masturbate because a
world record first time anyone says that
was the point of this room if there's
nothing mister share so share tell me
going on here
there's got to be something why did that
scare me all right yeah that's good we
good I finally I don't read key all
right
good yeah progress III stupid game keep
scaring me I gotta say I wanna save yes
finally
see see okay what are we going
it's so dark I'm scared I know I'm
Consuela but Skewes crisis is getting me
what am i but it says I need to find
blue and red key I mean blue key oh I've
voice cracks I like I find the item
picture book finally always I picture
what let's look at it that's beautiful
what are they doing this is a puzzle yes
it's definitelya buzzes hi
alright so he's like by octopus I gotta
go to school
no he's gonna head out octopus I'm gonna
rape yeah he's like nah don't write me
fine Adam bookmark okay I told her any
puzzles
I don't even know how to do it I black
whoo you're green thank you hello penny
I'm a plant but she can't pan can't move
what's the point of that yes yes it's so
much better now
hi gamba okay the cold is I am Nakhla it
what happened gets by the secret are
there darling Rach
okay what if I'm just any more deaf I
told many puzzles though many puzzles my
penis oh yes
what are you doing here how do you find
me in the beige man oh I'm glad the
light is on at this alright sorry mr.
plant but I need you to move out finding
out the picture back oh yeah let's see
with that am I supposed to figure out
the code now or something I mean seems
like how all this stuff I just this
place I don't test it at all
okay let's cheat I mean I'm gonna I'm
gonna take like five minutes and try to
think okay I am back
hi I caught um apparently I think I'm
just using my intuition here
there's something here is that north of
the bath
ah why can I say I'm a genius
what can I say I just it's it's just
comes to me it's like that it's more
like sucking out like me okay whatever
that is
ah that's a bummer okay well I have to
shoot again then okay so what Mac I of
course know what though I we're gonna
use haha okay and now we're gonna use
not cheating right anything
yours filler that through there change
colors head I don't know don't judge me
all right
flat head okay yes and then ah ah yes
didn't work
advise computer ok we're back and I'm
not gonna cheat one more I mean I never
cheated okay we put this air and then
we're supposed to count the dots it's 1
2 3 4 5 6 7
blue dots 3 white to green one red okay
okay so the cold is I remember I don't
even know anymore
uh one ai-ai-ai-ai one Dorothy fine
naya-a Caramba
I won toward a four five six seven
yes yes uh tall green III do you write
please work please work
hi hi I work better work example if
there's one read that there is one right
now all right
like that fur for blue dot one two three
four five six seven salad okay oh yeah
and then if it's too green we have to me
if it's three wide then it's rewind
we're back hey ah wait red green white
blue red this one where I'm how many
green one - I changed it
ah the son of a [ __ ] ok so it's one
two three
like they live in the frequency there we
go
I'm a hacker you got a problem always a
hacker okay oh come on give me a break
I tell you what the [ __ ] buzz it oh yeah
it's so comfortable I don't trust them
is it safe can I go ah that you stupid
son of a [ __ ] I want to come get my
beautiful hair
never ever it's my hair okay what's
going on here I don't want you to get it
all you've been that good are you okay
yeah but twisted my ankle I waited for a
bit okay I fought a little while ago
take it with you
I finally out I'm feeling it the [ __ ] do
fit the Dominic you stop inside a [ __ ]
vinegar Wow
mr. wall with a stupid ass on oh yeah I
caught him I been the guy she gives me a
my god
okay let's see what do we do with
vinegar
hi wait maybe I miss something maybe my
intuition tells me that there is
something about this carpet what about
this carpet I
walk on the spot and examine how
examiner supposed to be something here
maybe I'll use the vinegar crisps
I smoked it yes [ __ ] it with vinegar so
yes of course
whoa that's nice okay I think I knew
where actually we're gonna go okay fine
I'll wait I need this disk there's
supposed to be a disk here walk-on spot
examine it
another the left most corner of the
carpet is bit you for walk up to that
spot and examine oh there we go
I did finally ivan tedesco okay let's go
let's go this is the last thing I live
for ray alright [ __ ] I did a lot of
stuff ok let's go to the gate I know our
safest way first
saves Asians caralho mushrooms it's
gotta be here right okay yes does it
haha
Oh got a DD and stuff wow what is this
there's a button press the button see
okay press the bottom C press the bottom
C now I did nothing okay
maybe the disc tells me ah there's a DVD
I should use it at the desk
I'm a genius oh yay cut um put the disc
whoa wait
okay clockwise it does an arrow ah oh
so it's red yellow yellow blue red
yellow I will never remember this
there's no way okay
red yellow yellow blue oh god damn it I
already forgot desk
this is that red yellow yellow blue red
nah press it yellow yes yellow yes
blue yes and come on work work Toby oh
you died so many puzzles so many puzzles
Oh yellow
I forgot the yellow I told you how to
merge my forever okay
red yellow guess see see I see yellow
see
come on baby yeah yes yes funny at the
metal sting oh I can use this for my
hair again what about okay where are you
I don't do with a metal stake whatever
this [ __ ] game I'm taking a break and
hopefully I don't even know anymore
freakin long this game ever again haha
Oh do something Oh
Oh dah dah dang it dang it
ah ah ah